veamos si podemos simplificar esta
expresión y como siempre te invito a que
hagas una pausa y trates de resolver
este problema por tu propia cuenta muy
bien analicemos esta expresión que de
hecho se ve bastante interesante verdad
porque esta expresión ahora tiene dos
variables pero esencialmente lo que
vamos a hacer es la misma idea que hemos
desarrollado para una sola variable por
ejemplo en el numerador podemos ver que
todos estos coeficientes son divisibles
entre 5 así que podemos factorizar este
5 así que pensemos que debe múltiplo
digamos 5 debe multiplicar a qué
expresión para que nos dé este numerador
bueno pues aquí tendría que multiplicar
x cuadrada verdad 5 x x cuadrada de 5 x
cuadrada
4 y lo voy a poner así por equis ya
verán por qué lo pongo así de tal suerte
que 5 por 4 y x nos da 20 x 20 x es lo
mismo verdad
4g cuadrada para que al multiplicarlo
nos dé 20 que cuadrada muy bien y todo
esto irá dividido entre este denominador
pero vamos a buscar una forma de
expresar a este denominador digamos de
forma simplificada o vamos a tratar de
factorizar lo es decir vamos a pensar en
dos números que multiplicados nos den
menos 6 ye cuadrada y vamos a pensar en
que esos números al sumarlos si quieren
lo voy a escribir así como menos x
verdad entonces esos números al sumarlos
nos debe dar menos de verdad que es como
el coeficiente de x entonces lo voy a
escribir dos números que multiplicados
nos den menos 6 y cuadrada esos números
serían a y b y que al mismo tiempo al
sumarlos a esos números nos dé menos y
muy bien entonces de aquí podemos intuir
que esos dos números deben tener digamos
deben depender de verdad por ejemplo
aquí podríamos pensar en qué
a puede ser algo porque ve puede ser
algo por jeff y entonces en realidad
tendremos que pensar dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 6 y sumados
me den menos 1 verdad es como si lo
pensáramos sin la 10 digamos sólo los
números verdad entonces por ejemplo aquí
sería menos tres y más dos
vamos a ver si esto funciona menos 3 y 2
entonces si nosotros multiplicamos esto
nos da menos 6 cuadrada y si sumamos
menos tres más dos esto nos da menos así
que estos dos números o estas dos
expresiones menos 3 y 2 son los que
necesitamos para factorizar esta
expresión
digamos vamos a ver un caso análogo para
que sea un poco más intuitivo piensen en
x cuadrada menos menos x
-6 muy bien y aquí tenemos una expresión
similar verdad es de hecho análoga
entonces si pensamos en dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 6 y sumados
menos 1 pues justamente tendremos x
menos 3 x x + 2
x2 verdad pero en nuestra expresión que
teníamos aquí arriba nosotros teníamos
y cuadrada verdad lo cual hace que esta
expresión tenga que modificarse
poniéndole de verdad entonces esa
digamos sería la única diferencia así
que si realmente no te sientes seguro de
lo que hemos escrito hasta este momento
haz la multiplicación para que te puedas
convencer de que esto es correcto muy
bien entonces vamos a escribir estas
expresiones en este denominador será
exactamente igual a x menos 3 y que
multiplica a x + 2 y entonces hasta este
momento no parece que podamos
simplificar toda esta expresión así que
vamos a tener que trabajar el numerador
como lo hicimos con el denominador vamos
a factorizar la verdad así que vamos a
continuar digamos acá abajo
ok vamos a continuar acá abajo y esto
que será igual bueno tenemos que pensar
en dos expresiones que multiplicadas me
den cuatro y cuadrada y sumadas me den 4
y así que podremos pensar en 12 y 12
verdad 12 por dos es cuatro y cuadrada y
dos más dos son cuatro y así que esto
simplemente se escribirá como 5 por x +
2 y por x + 2
y todo esto dividido entre esta
expresión morada que es x menos 3 y y
multiplicando a x + 2 y muy bien
entonces ahora sí que podemos
simplificar esta expresión verdad porque
tenemos los mismos factores x + 2 y
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador así que podríamos
simplificar los es decir cancelar los
pero
para que esto sea digamos algebraica
mente equivalente
tenemos que pedirle que x + 2 ya sea
distinto de 0 verdad x + 2 ya sea
distinto de 0 porque originalmente no
podía ser verdad no podíamos dividir
entre 0 en esta expresión así que si la
quitamos hay que conservar esta
restricción de que x + 2 sea 0 o bien
que x tiene que ser distinta de menos 2
y muy bien entonces podríamos incluso
reescribir esto de forma todavía más más
simple verdad al multiplicar o al usarla
la propiedad distributiva en este
producto y lo que obtendríamos es 5x +
10 y todo esto
/ / x menos 3 g y para que esto sea
algebraica mente equivalente hay que
pedir que x sea distinto d
2 y entonces esta expresión de aquí es
algebraica mente equivalente a la que
teníamos originalmente verdad pero al
menos esta expresión es mucho más simple